gpt-3
similar to gdp 2 actually
have captivated some part of the
imagination of the public
there's just a bunch of hype of
different kind that's
i would say it's emergent it's not
artificially manufactured it's just like
people just get excited for some strange
reason and in the case of gpt 3 which is
funny
that there's i believe a couple months
delay from a release to
hype maybe i'm not
historically correct on that but it
feels like there was a little bit of a
lack of hype and then there's a phase
shift into into
hype but nevertheless there's a bunch of
cool applications
that seem to captivate the imagination
of the public about what this
language model that's trained in
unsupervised way
without any fine-tuning is able to
achieve
so what do you make of that what are
your thoughts about gbt3
yeah so i think what's interesting about
gpts3 is the idea that it may be
able to learn new tasks in
after just being shown a few examples so
i think if it's actually
capable of doing that that's novel and
that's very interesting and that's
something we should investigate
that said i must say i'm not entirely
convinced
that we have shown it's it's capable of
doing that
it's very likely given the amount
of data that the model is trained on
that what it's actually doing is
pattern matching uh a new task you give
it
with the task that it's been exposed to
in its training data it's just
recognizing the task
instead of just developing a model of
the task
right but there's a side to interrupt
there's a parallel to what you've said
before
which is it's possible to see gpt 3
as like the prompts that's given as a
kind of
sql query into this thing that it's
learned similar to what you said before
which is languages used to query the
memory
yes so is it possible that neural
network is a giant memorization thing
but then if it gets sufficiently giant
it'll memorize sufficiently
large amounts of thing in the world or
it becomes
more intelligence becomes a querying
machine i think it's possible that
uh a significant chunk of intelligence
is this giant associative memory
uh i definitely don't believe that
intelligence is
just a giant illustrative memory but it
may well be
a big component so
do you think gpt 3 4
5 gpt 10 will eventually
like what do you think where's the
ceiling do you think you'll be able to
reason um no that's a bad question uh
like what is the ceiling is the better
question how well is it gonna scale
how good is gptn going to be yeah
so i believe gptn is gonna
shifty tn is gonna improve on the
strength
uh of gpt2 and three which is it it will
be able to generate you know
uh ever more plausible text uh in
context
just monitoring the process performance
um
yes if you trade if you're training
bigger more on more data
then uh your text will be increasingly
more
uh context aware and increasingly more
plausible in the same way that gpt 3
it is much better at generating
clausable text compared to gpd2
um but that said i don't think just
scaling up
the model to more transformer layers and
more training data is going to address
the flaws
of lgbt3 which is that it can generate
possible texts but that text is
not constrained by anything else other
than plausibility
so in particular it's not constrained by
factualness
or even consistency which is why it's
very easy to get gpt3 to generate
statements that are
factually untrue uh or to generate
statements that are even
self-contradictory
right uh because it's uh it's its
only goal is plausibility and it has no
other constraints
it's not constrained to be
self-consistent for instance right
and so for this reason one thing that i
thought was very interesting with gpd3
is that
you can place the mind the answer it
will give
you by asking the question in specific
way because it's very responsive to the
way you ask the question
since it has no understanding of the
content of the question
right and if you if you have the same
question
in two different ways that are basically
adversarially
uh engineered to produce set an answer
you will get uh
two different answers to contractor
answers it's very susceptible to
adversarial attacks essentially
potentially yes
so in in general the problem with these
models is genetic models is that
they're very good at generating possible
text but that's just
that's just not enough right um
uh you need uh i think one one avenue
that would be very uh
interesting to make progress is to make
it possible
uh to write programs over the latent
space
that these models operate on that you
would rely
on these self-supervised models to
generate a sort of flag
pool of knowledge and concepts and
common sense and then you will be able
to write
explicit reasoning programs over it
uh because the current problem with gpt
three is that you
it's it's it can be quite difficult to
get it to
do what you want to do uh if you want to
turn gpd3 into products you need to put
constraints on it
you need to force it to
obey certain rules so you need a way to
program it explicitly
yeah so if you look at its ability to do
program synthesis
it generates like you said something
that's plausible yeah so
if you if you try to make it generate
programs it will perform well
uh for any program that that has seen it
in its training data
but because uh program space is not
interpretive right
um it's not going to be able to
generalize to problems it hasn't seen
before
now that's currently do you think
sort of an absurd but i think useful
um i guess intuition builder is uh
you know the gpt-3 has 175 billion
parameters
human brain has a hundred about a
thousand times that or
or more in terms of number of synapses
do you think um obviously
very different kinds of things but
there is some degree of uh similarity
do you think what what do you think gpt
will look like
when it has a hundred trillion
parameters
you think our conversation might be in
nature different
like because you've criticized gpt3 very
effectively now
do you think no i don't think so
so the the to begin with the bottleneck
with scanning lgbt
gbt models generative retrain
transformer models
is not going to be the size of the model
or how long
it takes to train it the bottleneck is
going to be the trained data
because openui is already training gpt3
on a crore of basically the entire web
right and that's a lot of data so you
could imagine training on more data than
that like google could try on more data
than that
but it would still be only incrementally
more data
and i don't recall exactly how much more
data gpg3 was strained on compared to
gpt2 but it's probably at least like
100 or maybe even 1000x i don't have the
exact number
uh you're not going to be able to train
the model on 100 more data than with
what you're
with what you're already doing so that's
that's brilliant so
it's not you know it's easier to think
of compute as a bottleneck
and then arguing that we can remove that
bottleneck but we can remove the compute
bottleneck i don't think it's a big
problem
if you look at the at the base at which
we've uh
improved the efficiency of deep learning
models
in the past a few years i'm not worried
about
training time bottlenecks or model size
bottlenecks
the the bottleneck in the case of this
generative transformer models is
absolutely the training data
what about the quality of the data so so
yeah so the quality of the data is an
interesting point the thing is
if you're going to want to use these
models in real products
then you you want to feed them data
that's
as high quality as factual i would say
as
unbiased as possible but you know
there's there's not really such a thing
as
unbiased data in the first place but you
probably don't want to to train it uh
on reddit for instance that sounds like
a bad plan
so from my personal experience working
with uh
large-scale deep learning models so at
some point i was working on
a model at google that's trained uh on
uh
extra 150 million uh labeled images
it's an image classification model
that's a lot of images that's like
probably most publicly available images
on the web at the time
and it was a very noisy data set because
the labels
were not originally annotated by hand by
humans they were
automatically derived from like tags and
social media
or just keywords in in the same page as
the image was fun and so on so it was
very noisy and
it turned out that you could easily get
a better model not just by training like
if you train on more
of the noisy data you get an
incrementally better model but you you
you very quickly hit diminishing returns
on the other hand
if you try on smaller data set with
higher quality annotations quality that
are
annotations that are actually made by
humans you get a better model
and it also takes you know less time to
train it uh yeah that's fascinating
it's the self-supervised learning
there's a way to get better
doing the automated labeling
yeah so you can enrich
or refine your labels in an automated
way
that's correct do you have a hope for um
i don't know if you're familiar with the
idea of a semantic web
is this a semantic web just for people
who are not familiar
and is uh is the idea of being able to
convert
the internet
or be able to attach like semantic
meaning to
the words on the internet this the
sentences the paragraphs
to be able to control convert
information on the internet or some
fraction of the internet
into something that's interpretable by
machines
that was kind of a dream
for um i think the the semantic white
papers in the 90s
it's kind of the dream that you know the
internet is full of rich exciting
information even in just looking at
wikipedia
we should be able to use that as data
for machines
so information is not it's not really in
a format that's available to machines so
no i don't think the semantic web
will ever work simply because it would
be
a lot of work right to make to
provide that information in structured
form and there is not really any
incentive for anyone to provide that
work
so i think the way forward to make
the knowledge on the web available to
machines is actually
something closer to unsupervised deep
learning
yeah the gbt3 is actually a bigger step
in the direction of making the knowledge
of the web available to machines
than the semantic web was yeah perhaps
in a human-centric sense it it feels
like
gpt-3 hasn't learned
anything that could be used
to reason but uh that might be just the
early days
yeah i think that's correct i think the
forms of reasoning that you that you see
it perform
are basically just reproducing patterns
that it has seen
string data so of course if you're
trained on
the entire web then you can produce an
illusion of reasoning
in many different situations but it will
break down if it's presented with a
novel
situation that's the opening question
between the illusion of reasoning and
actual reasoning
yes the power to adapt to something that
is genuinely new
because the thing is even imagine you
had
uh you could train on
every bit of data ever generated uh
in the history of humanity uh it remains
so that model would be capable of of
anticipating
many different possible situations but
it remains that
the future is going to be something
different like
um for instance if you train a gpt
stream model
uh on on data from the year 2002 for
instance
and then use it today it's going to be
missing many things it's going to be
missing many common sense
facts about the world it's even going to
be missing vocabulary and so on
yeah it's interesting that uh gbt3 even
doesn't have
i think any information about the
coronavirus
yes which is why you know
a system that's uh you you tell that the
system is intelligent when it's capable
to adapt
so intelligence is going to require uh
some amount of continuous learning
but it's also going to require some
amount of improvisation like
it's not enough to assume that what
you're going to be
asked to do is something that you've
seen before
or something that is a simple
interpolation of things you've seen
before
yeah in fact that model breaks down for
uh even even very
tasks that look relatively simple from a
distance
like l5 self-driving for instance
google had a paper a couple of years
back
showing that something like 30 million
different road situations were actually
completely insufficient to train
a driving model it wasn't even l2 right
and that's a lot of data that's a lot
more data than the
the 20 or 30 hours of driving that a
human needs
to learn to drive given the knowledge
they've already accumulated
you